Esta es la primera reunión de los
ministros de exteriores de la Unión
Europea de este año marcado
inevitablemente en la agenda por la
guerra en Ucrania durante esta semana
tal y como hemos escuchado se está
discutiendo mucho sobre este envío de
los carros de combate de estos tanques
leopard de producción alemana y que
tiene a los países europeos muy
divididos especialmente ahora mismo en
que Rusia está aumentando la ofensiva en
el este de Ucrania el jefe de la
diplomacia europea josep borreia su
entrada Aquí en esta reunión ha
insistido en que se debe apoyar a
Ucrania Aunque es ya la Unión Europea ha
hecho mucho está a favor de enviar estos
carros de combate pero evidentemente no
es una decisión que dependa de la Unión
Europea sino de los estados miembros que
comentábamos están muy divididos todo el
mundo está pendiente de lo que haga
Alemania aunque los países del este como
Polonia pero también los bálticos han
decidido que decidan lo Que decida
Alemania van a seguir adelante con el
apoyo a precisamente el apoyo a Ucrania
va a estar en esta agenda se espera que
los ministros den su visto bueno
político a esta ayuda de 500 millones de
euros más para el envío de armas por
parte de la Unión Europea una decisión
única que se estableció hace casi un año
cuando empezó la guerra en Ucrania por
el momento la Unión Europea ya ha
enviado más de 3.000 millones de euros
en inversión del envío de armas a
Ucrania esta ayuda se va a hablar entre
los ministros hoy por videoconferencia
con el ministro ucraniano dimitroculevar
algo que viene siendo habitual en estos
encuentros de los ministros aquí en
Bruselas